Wie viele Alkoholiker kennt ihr?
Ich kenne keinen einzigen – bis jetzt.
Ich habe Whiskey getrunken.
- Whiskey?
Mhm.
Am Schluss habe ich zwei Flaschen pro Tag getrunken.
Zwei Flaschen Whiskey?
Ja.
Man hat es irgendwann nicht mehr im Griff.
Und man muss einfach trinken.
Alle haben getrunken. Es war normal.
Bei den anderen ist es wieder aus dem Leben verschwunden.
Bei mir war das nicht der Fall.
Ich habe einfach weitergetrunken.
Das ist noch krass: Du warst mit einer Alkoholikerin verheiratet und hast es nicht gemerkt?
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Je mehr er mich geschlagen hat, desto mehr habe ich getrunken.
Darum meinten meine Kinder, ich solle nichts mehr sagen,
dann schlägt er dich auch nicht mehr.
Drei Tage auf den Spuren der Volksdroge Nummer eins.
Das ist "Mona Mittendrin" bei Alkoholikern
Angefangen hat alles mit einer Adresse in der Zürcher Innenstadt.
Dort erwartet mich jemand, haben sie gesagt.
Wer das ist? Keine Ahnung.
Hallo?
- Hallo.
Hier ist jemand.
Entschuldigung. Ich bin Mona Vetsch
und werde erwartet.
Du bist richtig hier.
Ich bin Felix, ich bin Alkoholiker.
Willkommen im Klub.
- Vielen Dank.
Ich bin Mona.
Wir sind in den Räumlichkeiten
von den Anonymen Alkoholikern.
Ich komme zu euch?
- Ja.
Ich komme
zu den Anonymen Alkoholikern?
Aber jetzt seid ihr
nicht mehr anonym.
Richtig.
Ich kenne bereits deinen Vornamen.
Ist das kein Problem?
Nein, denn wir sind hier
im privaten Rahmen.
Das ist also kein richtiges Meeting?
Nein,
das ist eine private Angelegenheit.
Wir beide werden uns outen.
Und Liz wird sich versteckt zeigen.
Hey, ich bin ein bisschen ...
Darf ich mich setzen?
Zuerst einmal durchatmen
und hinsetzen.
Vielen Dank.
Du bist Alkoholikerin?
- Ja.
Du auch?
- Ich auch. Trockene Alkoholikerin.
Du möchtest nicht gefilmt werden.
Nur von der Seite und von hinten.
Um so meine Familie zu schützen.
Sie hat am meisten gelitten.
Ich habe bis 40 getrunken.
Wie lange insgesamt?
- Elf Jahre.
Mit 29 war ich geschieden.
Ich hatte drei kleine Kinder.
Zwei-, fünf- und siebenjährig.
Ich lernte
einen anderen Mann kennen.
Als ich mit ihm ausging,
bestellte er
zwei Kaffees Crème mit Schnaps.
Das war so eklig,
ich musste mir die Nase zuhalten.
Ich fragte oft:
"Wie kann man so was trinken?"
Kaffee mit Schnaps.
- Ja.
Ich bestellte noch einen.
Und zwar wegen des tollen Gefühls.
Einfach ...
ein warmes, schönes Gefühl.
Das war der Anfang
von meiner Säuferkarriere.
Ein Kaffee mit Schnaps? Als Anfang?
- Ja.
Mit dem Alkohol wurde
immer alles ein Stück peppiger.
Ich trank Whiskey.
- Whiskey? - Ja.
Am Schluss
trank ich zwei Flaschen pro Tag.
Zwei Flaschen Whiskey?
- Hm-m.
Einen Teil musste ich trinken,
damit ich überhaupt aufstehen,
zur Arbeit gehen kann.
Damit ich funktionieren kann.
Wie du morgens zwei Kaffee trinkst,
brauchte ich zwei Whiskeys.
Also so richtige, damit ich
zur Arbeit, die Zähne putzen kann.
Darum musstest du Whiskey trinken?
- Ja, ohne hätte ich mich übergeben.
Ich müsste mich mit übergeben. Das
ist doch eklig mit der Zahnpaste.
Du denkst: "Ich kann mir das
nicht mehr vorstellen."
Ich bin ein kompletter
Un-Alkoholiker.
Ich mag es nicht ...
... ich habe eher Berührungsängste.
Ich habe mich gefragt,
ob ich Alkoholiker kenne.
Ich kenne niemanden. Also ...
Ich hätte es nie zugegeben.
Du lachst, aber ich kenne wirklich
niemanden. Warum lachst du?
Weil ...
Ich kann nur von mir sprechen,
aber als ich noch getrunken habe,
kannte ich genügend Möglichkeiten,
wie ich das vor meinen Bekannten
verbergen konnte.
Dachte ich zumindest.
Ich war keine Alkoholikerin,
ich habe nur getrunken.
Alle haben das gemacht.
Wir hingen rum,
und alle haben getrunken.
Es war ziemlich normal.
Im Ausgang?
- Genau.
Bei den anderen
hat sich das verwachsen,
aber nicht bei mir.
Ich habe weitergetrunken.
Ich merkte,
dass es auch sonst im Leben gut ist,
wenn ich Alkohol trinke.
Um nach der Arbeit runterzufahren.
Ich hatte damals nur Scheissjobs,
oder hatte das Gefühl,
nur Scheissjobs zu haben.
Ja, um runterzufahren.
Meist habe ich die Flasche
zügig entsorgt.
Damit nicht
zu viele Flaschen rumstehen
und mein Mann nicht denkt ... "Hä?".
"Ist das von einer Woche?"
Hat er gemerkt, wie viel du trinkst?
Ich weiss nicht,
das müsstest du ihn fragen.
Wie ging es dir?
Ich musste viel trinken,
damit ich schlafen konnte.
Damit ich irgendwie schlafen konnte
und morgens ...
Nein, ich habe nicht
an den Morgen gedacht.
Kommt dir das bekannt vor,
was Sibylle ...
Es gibt überall etwas,
das ... einem bekannt vorkommt.
Zu Beginn war ich ein Konsument
wie jeder andere.
Dem Alkohol verfallen bin ich erst,
als ich zu arbeiten angefangen habe.
Ich war nicht sehr glücklich
mit der Arbeit.
V.a. nicht mit dem Umfeld.
Damit es mir besser ging,
trank ich ein Feierabendbier.
Mit der Zeit merkte ich,
dass ich lockerer bin,
wenn ich getrunken habe.
Ich hatte zu wenig Selbstvertrauen.
Das habe ich mit Alkohol
etwas aufgepeppt.
Wie viel hast du pro Tag getrunken?
Gegen Schluss war es eine
Flasche Wodka, eine Flasche Whiskey.
Zusätzlich noch etwas mit Aroma.
Also: Bier, Wein.
Jeden Tag?
- In 24 Std., ja.
Manchmal kam es vor, dass ich
um 3 Uhr morgens aufgewacht bin,
eine Unruhe in mir spürte
und gemerkt habe,
wenn ich das jetzt nicht bekämpfe,
kann ich nicht mehr schlafen.
Und ich muss schlafen,
bis ich zur Arbeit muss.
Bist du dann
zum Kühlschrank gegangen?
Ich stand auf und trank einen
kräftigen Schluck Wodka, Whiskey
oder was gerade herumstand.
Dann ...
... dieses Gefühl,
dass ich wieder schlafen kann.
Dann stand ich wie gewohnt auf
und ...
Gib ihm!
(Felix ist heute trocken.)
(Auch Sibylle und Liz
trinken nicht mehr.)
(Aber der Alkohol
hat ihr Leben geprägt.)
(Ihre Geschichten
stehen für die Macht des Alkohols.)
(Für viele ist er ein
gesellschaftliches Schmiermittel.)
(Aber für gewisse eine
unbarmherzige und tödliche Droge.)
(Ca. 300'000 Schweizerinnen
und Schweizer sind alkoholsüchtig.)
(Jeder Fünfte von uns hat laut BAG
einen problematischen Konsum,
trinkt also zu viel oder zu oft.)
(Es sind immer noch mehr Männer,
die trinken.)
(Aber die Frauen holen auf.)
(Liz konsumierte lange
gar keinen Alkohol.)
(Sogar an ihrer eigenen Hochzeit
stiess sie mit Orangina an.)
(Drei Kinder brachte Liz zur Welt.
Dann ging ihre Ehe in die Brüche.)
(Dann verliebte sich Liz
in den falschen Mann.)
(Sie begann,
mit ihm exzessiv zu trinken.)
(Er wurde ihr gegenüber
immer wieder gewalttätig.)
Je mehr er mich geschlagen hat -
das war das Schlimme -
desto mehr habe ich getrunken.
Darum sagten meine Kinder,
ich solle nichts mehr sagen,
damit er mich nicht mehr traktiere.
Dann gab es ein Schlüsselerlebnis.
Er hat mich am Wochenende
wieder einmal im Zimmer eingesperrt.
Es gab einen Schrank mit Alkohol.
Er liess mich in diesem Zimmer
mit dem Alkohol.
Da habe ich sehr viel getrunken,
stell dir vor.
Er hat dich eingesperrt ...
- Ja.
Zum Essen durfte ich runter.
Am dritten Tag kam ich runter -
ich hatte schon recht Öl am Hut.
Alles, was in der Küche war,
nahm ich
und wollte es ihm
an den Kopf werfen.
Ich traf ihn aber nicht.
In diesem Moment merkte,
ich dass ich ihn totschlagen könnte.
Wirklich?
- Ich spürte es.
Du wusstest,
so geht es nicht weiter.
Egal, was passiert.
Ich ging zur Wohnungsfürsorge.
Ich sagte, ich brauche eine Wohnung.
Sie sagten, in 14 Tagen
könnte ich einen Wohnung haben.
Um 2 Uhr morgens schmiss er mich
mit den Kindern aus der Wohnung.
Mona, ich stand auf der Strasse.
Mit drei Kindern,
einem Auto, 168 Fr.
und ich war besoffen.
Nicht nüchtern,
hatte viele Promille intus.
Du meine Güte.
Du warst am Boden.
Zuunterst.
Notwohnung. Du hattest nichts mehr.
- Genau.
Aber ich war weg von diesem Elend.
Als du diesen Mann verlassen hast
und diese Notwohnung hattest:
Wie war es dann mit dem Trinken?
In diesem Moment war ich überzeugt,
dass ich mit Trinken
aufhören könnte.
Ich bin den Mann los
und muss nicht mehr trinken.
Das war ein grosser Trugschluss.
Ich war schon dermassen im Pegel
oder wie man dem sagen möchte.
Ich habe zwei Jahre weitergetrunken.
Ich habe es
jeden Morgen versprochen.
Ich kniete auf der Matratze.
"Heute höre ich auf, ganz sicher."
Ich versprach es den Kindern,
immer wieder.
Sie mussten immer mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen.
Wie war es für sie?
- Schlimm.
Schlimm.
Sie sagten nichts.
Sie versuchten zu funktionieren.
Die jüngere Tochter sagte:
"Mami, morgen ist Waschtag."
Oder: "Kannst du deine Bettwäsche
abziehen?"
"Du hast uns seit zwei Wochen
keine Bettwäsche mehr gegeben."
Gegessen haben sie im Hort.
Sie haben viel gekocht
und gingen Einkaufen.
Ich konnte nicht immer aus dem Haus.
- Ja.
Es gibt sicher Menschen,
die das nicht verstehen.
Eine Mutter liebt doch
nichts mehr als ihre Kinder.
Wenn man nicht mal für sie
auf Alkohol verzichten kann,
was ist das für eine Mutter?
Genau.
Darum schämt man sich auch so.
Wenn das schlechte Gewissen
gekommen ist,
musste ich gleich etwas trinken,
damit ich es nicht mehr spüre.
Dann war das schlechte Gewissen weg,
dann ist einem alles egal.
Man kann nicht mehr denken.
(Liz wollte jeden Tag aufhören,
fand aber keinen Ausweg.)
(Schliesslich war es ein Satz,
der alles veränderte.)
Dann sagte die Tochter: "Es ist
so schade, dass du so viel trinkst."
Das sagte sie liebevoll.
- Ja.
Das spürte ich.
Das bewegte mein Herz.
Ich spürte, dass sie mich liebt,
auch wenn ich
eine so furchtbare Mutter bin.
Ja.
War das der Moment ...
Da wusste ich,
dass ich etwas tun, aufhören muss.
Dann hast du AA angerufen,
also die Anonymen Alkoholiker?
Ich rief an, jemand hat den Anruf
entgegengenommen.
Ich ging hin.
Dann haben sie erzählt.
Jeder hat erzählt.
Es waren 24 Männer und eine Frau
sassen am Tisch.
Ja.
Und seit da hast du
nicht mehr getrunken? - Nein.
Ich kam
aus meinem eigenen Gefängnis raus.
Ja. Würdest du das so beschreiben?
- Ja. Aus meinem Gefängnis gekommen.
(Auch 35 Jahre später konnten
die Wunden nie richtig heilen.)
(Ihre Kinder
hätten ihr nie Vorwürfe gemacht.)
(Aber sie sich selber immer wieder.)
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Am nächsten Morgen
im aargauischen Fricktal.)
(In diesem 2'000-Seelen-Dorf
ist Felix aufgewachsen.)
(Als jüngstes von acht Kindern.)
(Er wohnt noch heute hier,
zusammen mit seinem Chow-Chow Bao.)
(Auch als er alkoholkrank war,
lebte er hier.)
So, warten wir.
- Hier ...
Gingst du hier jeweils einkaufen?
- Ja, das war eine Notlösung.
Die Verkäufer, die hier gearbeitet
hatten, waren Einheimische.
Sie haben dich gekannt.
- Genau.
Auswärts einkaufen war einfacher.
An einem Tag nahm ich
die Abkürzung über Deutschland.
Ich ging dort zum Einkaufen.
Am anderen Tag in der Schweiz.
Damit nicht aufgefallen ist,
dass ich schon wieder einkaufe,
eine gewisse Menge.
Manchmal kaufte ich dazu
noch drei Stangen Lauch.
Und etwas Speck.
So sah es
nach einem normalen Einkauf aus.
Woher kommt das,
dass man es verstecken möchte?
Scham.
Hast du dich geschämt?
- Ja.
Weil ich merkte, dass ich es
nicht mehr im Griff habe.
Ja, das ...
Irgendwann
hat man es nicht mehr im Griff.
Dann muss man trinken,
ich musste den Stoff haben.
Ich musste ihn besorgen.
- Du warst wie ein Junkie.
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Ich möchte nicht mehr zurück.
Die ganze Sache war einfach zu viel.
Hallo.
- Hallo. - Hallo.
Man kennt sich.
- Ja, nicht wahr?
Hat dich im Dorf
niemand darauf angesprochen
und gesagt:
"Felix, das kommt nicht gut."
Nein.
- Echt?
Aber das merkt man doch,
wenn sich jemand zurückzieht.
Nein, ich denke nicht,
dass die Leute darüber reden wollen.
Auf dem Land scheint es,
als wissen alle alles.
Man kenne sich gut.
Ja, aber nur nichts sagen.
Direkt ansprechen? Nein.
(Die Betroffenen verstecken es,
das Umfeld schaut weg.)
(Dasselbe passierte auch jahrelang
an Felix' Arbeitsplatz.)
(In seinem Job als Planer
bei einem Detailhändler
füllte Felix jeden Tag Wodka
in eine Rivella-Flasche ab,
die er in seinem Auto versteckte.)
(Vor der Kaffeepause trank er davon,
damit er die Kaffeetasse
ohne zu zittern halten konnte.)
(Bis er aufgeflogen ist.)
Jemand merkte, dass ich
immer zur gleichen Zeit ging,
um meinen Pegel aufzufüllen.
Er kam mir dann nach
und hat mich wohl gesehen.
Er fragte sich,
warum ich im Auto Rivella trinke.
Aha. Du bist ...
- Das ist ja nicht normal.
Ich wurde zitiert.
Mein Chef hat mich
zu einem Gespräch eingeladen.
Die Personalassistentin war dabei.
Und jemand vom Sozialamt.
Es wurde mir ganz direkt gesagt:
"Wir möchten Sie gerne behalten
aber wir haben festgestellt,
dass Sie ein Problem haben."
"Wenn Sie nichts dagegen tun,
sind wir gezwungen,
Konsequenzen zu ziehen."
Und ...
Die Sozialarbeiterin suchte
so rasch wie möglich einen Platz.
In einer Klinik.
- "Ich gebe Ihnen Bescheid."
"Sie müssen sich selber anmelden."
Glaubst du,
du hättest dich zu Tode gesoffen?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Meine Leberwerte
waren jenseits von Gut und Böse.
Ich hatte auch sonst
körperliche Probleme,
die im Nachhinein gesehen ganz klar
mit dem Alkohol zusammenhingen.
(Felix' Glück: Er konnte an
seinen alten Arbeitsplatz zurück.)
(Unter der Bedingungen:
Er besucht eine Selbsthilfegruppe.)
So ging Felix an eine Sitzung
der Anonymen Alkoholiker.
Irgendwie war ...
eine gewisse Geborgenheit vorhanden.
Die Leute waren nett.
Eingefahren ist mir der Erste,
der gesagt hat:
"Bei uns musst du nichts."
"Wir sagen nie:
'Hör auf zu saufen.'"
"Wir sagen nicht:
'Mach das so. Mach das so.'"
"'Du solltest das nicht tun.'"
"Sondern: 'Wir sprechen nur von uns,
wie wir die Probleme gelöst haben.'"
"'Das geben wir weiter.'"
Am Ende kam jemand
und gab mir seine Visitenkarte.
"Wenn es dir dreckig geht:
Ruf an."
Obwohl er dich
zum ersten Mal gesehen hat. - Ja.
Das war irgendwie ...
... befreiend.
Dass jemand da ist, der sagt:
"Ich kenne dich zwar nicht,
aber ich vertraue dir."
"Hier ist meine Karte."
Diese Karte
hatte ich lange im Portemonnaie.
Brauchte sie aber nie.
Aber du hattest sie.
Es war ein guter Entscheid.
Jetzt bin ich ...
seit einigen Jahren ...
... dabei.
Ich möchte es nicht missen,
denn es ist eine gute Sache.
Zumindest für mich.
* Treibende Musik *
(Vom Alkohol wegkommen
ist alles andere als einfach.)
(Auch Felix schaffte es nicht
beim ersten Versuch.)
(Nach acht Monaten ohne Alkohol
dachte er, ein Bier liege drin.)
(Ein paar Tage später
soff er wieder wie vorher.)
(Damit man auch auf lange Zeit
trocken bleibt,
ist der Austausch mit
Gleichgesinnten eine grosse Stütze.)
(Wie bei den Anonymen Alkoholikern.)
(Es gibt sog. offene Meetings,
bei dem auch Leute ohne Alk-Probleme
dabei sein dürfen.)
(In einem solchen Treffen bin ich.
Liz führt durch das Meeting.)
"Anonyme Alkoholiker sind eine
Gemeinschaft von Männern und Frauen,
die miteinander ihre Erfahrung,
Kraft und Hoffnung teilen,
um ihr gemeinsames Problem zu lösen
und anderen zur Genesung
vom Alkoholismus zu verhelfen."
"Unser Hauptzweck ist:
nüchtern zu bleiben
und anderen Alkoholikern
zu Nüchternheit zu verhelfen."
Mein Name ist Liz,
ich bin Alkoholikerin
und begrüsse euch herzlich
zum offenen Meeting.
Unser heutiges Thema ist:
der erste Schritt.
Wir gaben zu, dass wir
dem Alkohol gegenüber machtlos sind
und unser Leben
nicht mehr meistern konnten.
(In der Runde
sitzen Menschen wie du und ich.)
(Bei ihren Geschichten muss ich aber
immer wieder leer schlucken.)
(Niemand urteilt über den anderen.)
(Jeder weiss aus eigener Erfahrung,
wie man sein Leben
wegen des Alkohols versauen kann.)
(Unsere Kameras müssen nun raus.)
(Was in diesem Raum erzählt wird,
bleibt in diesem Raum.)
(1 1/2 Std. später
ist das Meeting beendet.)
(Jetzt treffe ich wieder
meine Dreierrunde:
Felix, Sibylle und Liz.)
Ich muss sagen:
Das hat mich tief beeindruckt.
Ich kannte das bisher
nur aus amerikanischen Filmen.
Da sieht es anders aus,
da sitzen alle im Kreis.
Bei euch sitzt man an Tischen.
Mich hat v.a. beeindruckt,
wie schonungslos hart,
offen und ehrlich
die Leute von sich selber
erzählt haben.
Auch ihre Geschichte.
Vor anderen Leuten.
Das ist der wichtigste Aspekt.
Ehrlich zu sich selbst sein.
Eindrücklich ist auch der Anfang.
Wenn du deinen Namen sagst:
"Ich bin Alkoholiker."
Warum müsst ihr das tun?
Wir müssen nicht,
aber wir tun es einfach.
Ich persönlich mache es,
um mir zu sagen: "Du bist krank."
Ich sage "Ich bin Alkoholiker"
und weiss ganz genau:
Die nächsten 24 Std. passe ich auf.
Egal ...
- Du bist seit zehn Jahren trocken.
Aber ich bin auch in 20, 30
oder 50 Jahren noch Alkoholiker -
wenn ich dann noch leben sollte.
Ihr sagt nicht von Anfang an:
"Ich trinke nie mehr."
Ihr sprecht immer nur
von den nächsten 24 Std.
Immer.
- Warum?
Nicht nur zu Beginn. Immer.
- Am Ende wünscht ihr euch:
Gute 24 Std.
- Gute 24 Std.
Woher kommt das?
Ich wäre durchgedreht,
wenn man mir gesagt hätte,
ich dürfe nie mehr etwas trinken.
Ich finde es auch gut ...
Diese 24 Std. sind zu Beginn
auch schon zu viel.
Man kann es sich auch einteilen.
Immer auf die nächste Stunde:
bis um 17, 18, 19 Uhr.
Das gibt jedes Mal
ein Erfolgserlebnis,
weil man noch nicht getrunken hat.
Das ist einfacher
zu bewerkstelligen.
Ich sage auch heute nicht, dass ich
bis ans Lebensende nie mehr trinke.
Ihr rechnet auch heute noch
mit diesen 24 Std.
Wenn man diese geschafft hat,
kommen die nächsten 24 Std.
Ja.
Was passiert, wenn ihr merkt,
dass jemand einen Rückfall hatte?
Ich erlebe das oft.
Bei der Hotline
ist meine Telefonnummer hinterlegt.
Wenn jemand in Not ist,
kann er mich anrufen.
Und dann?
Ich höre zu und sage,
dass ein Rückfall nicht schlimm ist.
"Das kann passieren. Komm wieder."
"Komm wieder. Versuch es."
Ich weiss, es ist nicht das Ende.
Es kann passieren.
Wir haben die Möglichkeit ...
Nach 24 Std. wieder neu anzufangen.
Heute.
Das sind tempi passati.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Alkoholsucht ist wie ein Fluss,
der einen mitzieht.)
(Um rauszukommen,
braucht man eine Ausstiegstelle:
eine Selbsthilfegruppe,
die Hand eines Freundes
oder den Rat einer Ärztin.)
(Alkoholkranke lassen
viele solcher Angebote ausser Acht.)
(Aber irgendwann kommt diese
Ausstiegstelle, die sie packen.)
(Ich besuche Sibylle.)
(Die selbstständige Texterin
wohnt am Rande von Zürich.)
Hoi, Sibylle.
- Hoi, Mona.
Komm rein.
- Danke.
(Sibylle hat mir angeboten,
ihren Mann zu fragen,
wie er ihre Alkoholabhängigkeit
erlebt habe.)
Ich bin Mona.
- Wir müssen so.
Ja, es ist immer noch schwierig.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
- Gleichfalls, merci.
(Oliver arbeitet bei einer
grossen Wirtschaftsprüferfirma.)
(Seit knapp 20 Jahren
sind er und Sibylle ein Paar.)
(Also schon seit Sibylle
mehr als nur Kaffee getrunken hat.)
(Wir schauen Fotos an
von der letzten gemeinsamen Reise,
bevor Sibylle zu den
Anonymen Alkoholikern gegangen ist.)
(Sibylle hat nach jahrelangem
Trinken unter dem Alkohol gelitten.)
(Körperlich und psychisch.
Im Job wurde es schwierig.)
(Als sie gegenüber ihrer Ärztin
endlich ehrlich war,
was ihren Alkoholkonsum betraf,
sagte diese, sie müsse sofort
etwas dagegen unternehmen.)
(Das Ende des heimlichen Trinkens
einer Flasche Prosecco
und einer Flasche Wein pro Tag.)
Ich war oft
zwischen 17 und 18 Uhr zu Hause.
Als Erstes habe ich etwas getrunken.
Oli arbeitet immer länger als ich.
Meistens bis 19 oder 19.30 Uhr.
Da war ich schon
bei meinem Glas Rotwein,
das er registriert hat.
Das hast du gesehen,
aber nicht, was vorher war.
Nein, das war für mich
das erste Glas.
Ich dachte,
das machen ja viele Leute.
Wie hast du ihr Trinkverhalten
eingeschätzt?
Sie hat sicher mehr getrunken
als andere.
Aber ich fand, es sei
immer noch im normalen Rahmen.
Alkohol war bei uns nie ein Thema.
Wir haben uns nie gefragt,
ob wir fürs Wochenende
genug Alkohol haben.
Sondern ...
- Du nicht, aber ich schon.
Klar, aber wir haben es
nicht diskutiert. - Nein.
Hast du die Flaschen
unter dem Sofa verstecken müssen?
Die vollen Flaschen nicht.
Aber die leeren schon.
Wenn in der Küche vier volle
Flaschen Wein gestanden hätten,
war das so.
Du hättest gedacht ...
- Ich führte kein Inventar.
Ich dachte vielleicht:
"Oh, haben wir nur noch
zwei Flaschen, nicht drei?"
Du hattest keinen Verdacht?
- Nein.
Gab es Momente, bei denen du
im Nachhinein denkst ...
Ja, es gab schon Phasen.
Einmal, das war schon sehr absurd.
Das war noch recht früh,
ca. 2002 oder 2003.
Wir hatten ein Abendessen.
Der Wein hatte Zapfen,
wir hatten keine andere Flasche.
Zu Hause?
- Ja, zu Hause.
Ich sagte: "Wir haben keinen Wein.
Trinken wir halt etwas anderes."
Du hast aber insistiert:
"Ohne Wein esse ich nicht."
Dann musste ich zur Tankstelle
fahren und Wein holen.
Wenn du mir das jetzt erzählst,
fast 20 Jahre später,
würde ich sagen: "Das war ja klar."
Jeder vernünftige Mensch
würde sagen:
"Der Wein hat Zapfen,
nehmen wir was anderes."
Das ist noch krass.
Du warst
mit einer Alkoholikerin verheiratet
und hast es nicht gemerkt.
- Ja.
Alles andere wäre gelogen.
Wirfst du dir vor,
dass du es nicht gemerkt hast?
Ja,
es lässt mich ja nicht gut dastehen.
Man hat das Gefühl,
der checke das einfach nicht.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen: Beruflich
war alles okay, sie war fit.
Wir haben vieles unternommen.
Der Alkohol stand nie im Fokus.
- Für dich.
Wie ist es heute?
Bei Sportlerunfällen
wird gerne etwas gezwitschert.
Darfst du vor Sibylle noch trinken?
- Ja. Aber ich trinke wenig.
Wir haben schon Bier zu Hause.
Könnte das für Sibylle
nicht gefährlich sein?
Ich vertraue ihr voll.
Ich denke nicht darüber nach.
Du denkst aber öfter darüber nach,
als du jetzt sagst.
Wenn wir im Restaurant essen
und der Kellner mit dem Wein kommt,
nimmst du mein Glas immer weg.
Wenn ich im Gespräch bin,
schaust du,
dass er mir keinen Wein einschenkt.
Du hast nicht Angst,
dass ich trinke,
sondern dass ich vor dem Glas sitze
und es wieder zurückgeben müsste.
Es schauen sicher viele zu,
die denken:
"Aha, ein bisschen Rotwein -
das mache ich auch."
"Bin ich jetzt auch ..."
Das fragt man sich tatsächlich.
Wo ist die Grenze
zwischen viel und zu viel?
Wenn man nicht mehr ohne kann.
Das war für mich der Moment.
Als ich keinen Tag mehr
ohne Alkohol schaffte.
Wenn es ohne dieses eine Glas
nicht mehr geht, dann ...
... ist etwas nicht gut.
Es gibt genug Menschen,
die ohne Alkohol auskommen.
(Wo beginnt Alkoholismus?)
(Und wie erkennt man ihn?)
(Oft bemerkt man von aussen nichts.)
(Trinkerinnen und Trinker
leben unauffällig unter uns.)
(Eine Freundin erzählte mir, ihre
Tante sei wegen Alkohol gestorben.)
(Niemand habe gemerkt, dass sie
trinke, nicht mal die Kinder.)
(Wer trinkt, fällt
in unserer Gesellschaft nicht auf.)
(Schliesslich trinken
über 80 % der Menschen Alkohol.)
(Weniger oder etwas mehr.)
Mir ist eingefahren, wie man
einen Blick dafür entwickelt,
wie wichtig Alkohol
in unserer Gesellschaft ist.
Wenn man etwas feiert,
wenn man anstösst,
im Freundeskreis,
trinken wir Alkohol.
Das ist der Alltag.
Das gehört zu unserer Kultur.
Ich bin nicht gegen Alkohol.
Ich weiss einfach,
dass ich Alkohol nicht vertrage.
Mich nerven jene, die insistieren,
auch wenn man sagt,
man trinke nicht.
"Komm schon, eines.
Nur zum Anstossen."
Wenn jemand hartnäckig war,
hatte ich oft Lust, zu sagen:
"Ich bin Alkoholikerin."
"Du willst nicht wissen,
wo es endet, wenn ich jetzt trinke."
Ich hätte sie gerne herausgefordert.
Was würden sie dann sagen?
Man muss sich oft rechtfertigen,
wenn man keinen Alkohol trinkt.
Das geht auch mir so
und ich mag ihn nur nicht.
Erlebst du das auch,
dass du dich rechtfertigen musst?
Ich habe gute Erfahrungen gemacht,
als ich sicherer geworden bin.
Ich habe dann jeweils
ganz trocken und bestimmt gesagt,
dass ich nichts trinken möchte.
Wenn jemand hartnäckig wurde,
fragte ich:
"Hast du gehört,
was ich gesagt habe?"
"Nein. Punkt." Dann war es erledigt.
Das verstehen alle.
Eine Frage,
die für mich noch unbeantwortet ist:
Was kann ich bei Arbeitskollegen
oder bei Familienangehörigen machen,
wenn man von einem Fall weiss.
Was kann ich selber beitragen?
Ansprechen?
- Ansprechen. - Ja?
Aber wie?
Liebevoll.
Und nicht anklagend: "Du hast ...",
sondern: "Ich denke ...",
oder "Ich habe das Gefühl ..."
Oder: "Ich bin für dich da,
falls du Hilfe brauchst."
Einfach liebevoll.
Das jemandem zu sagen,
ist nicht einfach.
Man könnte sagen:
"Ich habe festgestellt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt,
und ich mache mir Sorgen."
Auf keinen Fall: "Hör auf ...",
"Mach doch ..., "Du solltest ...".
"Geh zum Psychiater ..." oder so.
Das bringt absolut nichts.
Das ist kontraproduktiv.
Ich fühlte mich sehr allein
in einem solchen Moment,
wenn jemand so etwas sagte.
Das war der Grund,
um wieder zu trinken:
Ich werde nicht verstanden.
Wenn man mich nicht versteht,
brauche ich etwas: den Alkohol.
Alkohol bleibt für euch ein Thema.
Aber im Alltag, wenn nicht
ich daherkomme und euch ausfrage,
ist es immer noch präsent?
Ja.
Ja, es ist allgegenwärtig. Er ist
rechts, links, vorne und hinten.
Ich sehe ihn,
aber er macht mir nicht mehr weh.
So ist das für mich heute.
Er macht mir nicht mehr weh.
Es ist keine Schande, wenn man
diese Krankheit hat. - Nein.
Aber es ist sehr schlimm,
wenn man nichts dagegen macht.
Oder es kann schlimm enden.
(Etwas dagegen tun - das ist
bei Alkoholabhängigkeit schwierig.)
(Das wissen Felix, Liz und Sibylle
selber am besten.)
(Aber sie haben es geschafft.)
(Ihre Schicksale
haben mich beeindruckt,
aber noch mehr,
wie offen sie darüber reden.)
(Vielleicht helfen ihre Geschichten
dem einen oder der anderen,
um den Alkohol
hinter sich zu lassen.)